[Musique]
le département et la chambre de métiers
et de l'artisanat de la réunion signent
une convention afin de relancer
l'activité économique des petites et
moyennes entreprises touchées par la
crise du coronavirus le premier axe
consiste à orienter et à faciliter
l'accès des entreprises artisanales à la
commande publique départementale dans
son plan de relance économique et social
la collectivité investit près de 570
millions d'euros pour le développement
de l'activité locale et c'est important
et c'est là où intervient effectivement
le partenariat avec la chambre des
métiers
c'est que les les recrutent les
personnes qui seront recrutées à la
chambre des métiers vont les aider à
constituer leurs dossiers de réponses à
nos consultations et à nos appels
d'offres pour donner un coup de fouet à
la commande publique et aider nos
artisans était pieux qui sont en
difficulté aujourd'hui à cause de cette
crise et à cause du ralentissement de
notre économie et notre support de la
relance économique et le pass bien-être
la collectivité prévoit d'investir 16
millions d'euros dans ce dispositif
destiné aux bénéficiaires du rsa socle
ainsi qu'aux personnes âgées 2000
entreprises du secteur de l'artisanat
pourront intégrer ce dispositif sur le
passe bien net nous avons identifié au
moins deux professions de l'artisanat
ce sont les coiffeurs et les coiffeuses
de la réunion les et physicienne de la
réunion qui vont pouvoir s'inscrire sur
un site et donc qu'ils vont pouvoir
je dirais recevoir des chèques qui
seront donnés à des du public qui est
concerné par le conseil départemental
dans le cadre de ce dispositif dont les
gens pourront venir chez ses coiffeurs
esthéticiennes pendant cette période
keane période où je pense que les gens
ont besoin aussi de prendre soin d'eux 1
et donc c'est important
cette convention vise à accompagner la
relance économique de tout un secteur de
l'activité locale celui de l'artisanat
près de vingt mille entreprises seront
concernés par le plan de relance
économique et social porté par le
département de la réunion
[Musique]